let's start with the situation on the
ground explain what is going on
yes um Chloe this is the map that we're
all getting very familiar with
um the Russians want to take the hold of
the donbass if they take severity on yes
they've more or less got luhansk that's
the last City really in luhansk and
they're close to doing that but it will
be a big issue really to take the rest
of uh the the second oblast of John yet
but we will see we will see but if we
look a bit more closely at what's
happening happening in the city of
Donetsk you can see that the uh the
problem for uh the Russians is that they
are pushing forward they were at the
Eastern edge of the city yesterday
reports are that they're now half
through the urban area now and that's
entirely plausible it looks as if the
ukrainians may be having to pull back
and they may be coming onto the other
side of the river to lishansk which is
sensible from their point of view that's
a more defensible place to try to hold
the Russian offensive or at least slow
it down there are apparently between 10
and 15 000 civilians cillians very
Donetsk and so this is turning in into
another Mario poll not quite on that
scale but the same process I'm afraid
well different things I think things
adding in the in the north and elsewhere
I mean the ukrainians in the north they
had a big push at kharkiv a couple of
weeks ago and they succeeded in pushing
Russian Artillery away from the city
which which means that the city is free
from these Dreadful artillery barrages
although not from missile strikes I have
to say but that's Kaki was the Second
City it's getting back to something like
normal and the ukrainians are still
trying to push the Russians back their
own offensive are stalled a little bit
and the Russians are digging in so I
wouldn't expect those positions to
change very much uh in the coming week
or two but the ukrainians are certainly
holding their own and keeping kharkiv as
we're more or less free at the moment
and let's move down to the South and
talk a bit about what's going on there
because that's a strategically important
area as well yeah that's the next battle
after severi Donetsk uh this is the next
big battle the Russians were trying to
push southwards towards the coast as if
they wanted to actually attack Nikolai
from the south instead of from the East
which they tried to do before and failed
and that of course is a gateway to
Odessa still quite a long way away but
nevertheless they've got to get past
mclave before they can get to Odessa
which they certainly want to do but the
ukrainians while the Russians have been
trying to do this ukrainians have built
up their forces we could see this couple
of weeks ago a battle was developing
here and it's now started and the
ukrainians are pushing really very hard
and they think they seem to think that
they could get as far as Kirsten
reasonably soon well I'm not sure about
that but we'll see but the ukrainians
are more than holding their own here
they're giving the Russian something
else to worry about because if the
Russians do lose cursion that's the most
important city that they've captured so
far if they were to lose it even for a
short time that would be a very big
setback and so we'll see how that battle
goes that's not reached its peak yet I
guess but it certainly will do in the
next week or two we will watch with
baited breath Michael Clark our defense
analyst thanks so much for that